- Hi there, I'm Jennifer Garner
and I'm going to take a
BuzzFeed quiz to find out
which Jennifer Garner character I am.
(light-hearted music)
First, choose a Hollywood hunk:
Ryan Gosling, Henry Golding, great.
Mark Ruffalo, hm.
Josh Duhamel, Matthew
McConaughey, Will Smith.
Ideal.
(sputters)
How do you choose one of these guys?
I mean it's hard not to choose
one of them that I know.
Matthew I've worked with
twice so he wins, bink.
Next, pick your favorite movie genre:
horror, no.
Action.
I'm in an action film
and I do like this film
but typically I get too
stressed out, no thank you.
Romcom, yes.
Sci-fi, no.
Fantasy, meh.
Comedy, yes.
Romcom or comedy?
(clicks tongue)
I'm gonna have to go romcom.
Now choose your favorite favorite
Jennifer Garner red carpet look.
That's horrifying.
The 60th Golden Globes.
Wow, we were really going for period look
with the hair over the ears.
The 54th Emmy Awards,
that was Ralph Lauren.
That was pretty,
and that dress didn't come
together until that day.
75th Academy Awards.
Definitely not her.
The 80th Academy Awards.
(sighs) The long bang.
That's one of my favs.
88th Academy Awards, that's Versace,
and the 90th Academy Awards.
Whoa that blue dress was very blue.
Which one is the most me?
I really loved the hair
and the drama of this one.
Take that.
Pick your go-to movie theater snack.
Wine.
(chuckles) That was easy.
Choose a punny name for your pet chicken.
Mother Clucker.
That's good.
Dixie Chick, Princess Lay-a.
These are very good.
Gretch-hen Wiener.
I'm not gonna lie,
this is the toughest
one we've come across.
Goldie Hen, hm.
Princess Lay-a.
I'm Jenna Rink.
(laughs) I could have told
you that without doing this.
The person that I am closest
to is Jenna Rink, yes.
I'm 30 (chuckling), flirty and thriving.
Plus 16 years.
Whether you're closer in age to 30 or 13,
or the two combined, you are the lovable
and self-determined Jenna Rink.
People tend to be attracted
to your vibrant personality
and infectious presence.
And who can blame them?
You're the life of the
party in any setting.
With or without whipping out
the Thriller choreography.
I still know Thriller.
Though you have a tendency to wanna fit in
with the cool crowd,
I don't think that is true about me,
just that specific thing,
I'm not very good at the cool crowd.
You never stray too far away
from your authentic self.
I almost forgot, you're
flirty and thriving.
(clicks tongue) Flirty, thriving.
Yeah, I would agree with that.
I think I'm probably of all the
characters I've ever played,
I'm probably most like that chick.
(light-hearted music)